oh yeah it's one of those nights you
don't talk about stephen king without
getting some
cookie butter am i right i am not
sponsored
[Music]
the shining by steven reginald
king that's that's not his middle name
why am i doing this
well i read it i don't read a ton of
books
very fast people might tune in just to
hear about
the crunchy crunchy crunchy crunchy
delicious cookie butter this is what my
life is becoming
no don't lie to yourself this is not
what your life is becoming this is what
it is
this is what it has been you sick son of
a [ __ ]
this will be a spoiler-free discussion
about the book and review
but at a certain point i will start
talking spoilers so
at that time you should get the hell out
of here
and just read the book for yourself and
the movie you can't read the movie but
watch the movie not too long ago
i finished a little book called the wave
kings ever heard of it
and i really needed something of a
different pace
stephen king he's one of those writers
who i loved his work
in theory i would read beginnings i'd
get 100 pages in and then i'd feel like
yeah i've seen
uh you know i did that with misery i
need to go back and read it don't
[ __ ] at me don't at me the
the shining is my first proper stephen
king
read wow
wow
i'm getting ahead of myself
not the movie at all when i picked up
this book i thought i would be reading a
cold
thriller psychological horror what i
found was something
very warm very personal very
realistic despite certain things i'll
get to later and
sentimental as all hell i was like is
this a
[ __ ] spielberg movie in here yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] uh does this guy know how
to write
after reading the way of kings by
brandon sanderson i was getting
accustomed to a certain type of writing
that that's emphasis was on
clarity on precision on objectivity in a
lot of ways
so opening up the shining was really
exciting you know stephen king gets away
with
with such exciting internal
things in his characters certain
thoughts there's just like a
bunch of exclamation points on each
sides of
words giving this like forward momentum
this rush
your eyes are just moving down the page
easily it's so
easy to read beautiful i will be real
with you
[Music]
i'll i'll be real i thought that the
book got
more boring when they got to the
overlook hotel when it
started getting more paranormal and the
scares started happening
because stephen king did such a good job
getting me to care about this
family getting me to care about jack
torrance's
guilt his drinking problem about
wendy's relationship with her mom and
her relationship with jack
it just felt so intimate and engaging
from page one that by the time they got
to the hotel i just cared about these
people
spoilers about some of the stuff that
happens in the book
it diverges so so so so much from the
film
and i love the movie i am so attached to
that movie
but i started becoming attached to this
book in a way that was like almost like
it was parallel universes
just i have love for each of them in
very different ways and
what the shining movie does so well
the shining book does poorly and vice
versa
it is really bizarre dick halloran
became my favorite character just the
story of him
coming to the overlook took up a ton of
page time i didn't even mind just being
with him
his reminiscing his experiences with
hearing people's thoughts as he goes to
the airport
as he's on the plane his issues flying
and getting the snowmobile and riding up
towards the hotel
because he becomes so central to the
emotional heart of the story the
emotional
this family that that danny is able to
ultimately have
because of his abilities the way he's
able to actually
save his mom it's really touching
it's really a beautiful story
jack doesn't really overcome his demons
but
he manages in a way to kind of
save his family sort of i mean it gets
kind of freaky body horror
near the end of the book so do be warned
you really want jack
you just you just want the guy's life to
turn around he is struggling
and struggling and the overlook hotel is
the last
place this guy needs to be i thought
that the povs were
so uni each character thought
differently i loved
all of danny's povs i wish there were
maybe more
wendy povs because i thought her
character was really really
interesting i didn't love all of the uh
information and investigating that jack
does into the mob
as it relates to the overlook i thought
it was kind of cheesy
every time they talked about these these
gangsters it just seemed i just kept
thinking about like you know edward g
robinson smoking a cigar and
i see yeah listen here see those little
things in the
movie that are so creepy because they're
not explained
are explained exhaustively in the book
it's really not scary
it's just kind of interesting and that's
how i feel about the scares which brings
me to my next point don't expect to be
scared
really i know joey and friends was like
scared he had to throw the book into the
fridge or whatever
i mean i never start reading the shining
without making sure we got plenty of
room in the freezer
i i can't see most people finding this
scary
especially compared to the movie because
there is that
that comfort that sentimentality it
gives it so much
uh it makes it so exciting and that the
characters and
seeing inside their heads but the
mystery the coldness the
the thrill is there and the suspense but
the fear i don't know maybe if i hadn't
seen the movie
maybe like like honestly the scenes i
thought were the scariest
were the scenes that weren't in the
movie the hornets that was
freaky and weird and i was not expecting
that to
happen and i loved that that was the
first real sign
of bad stuff going on in the overlook
because it's just
weird enough to be it's not exactly
weird enough to be like
implausible just enough for jack to
start going
am i losing my mind or am i
just such a bad father that i just can't
catch a [ __ ] break
man it's just just watching him spiral
he he wants so hard to be
a great father he truly loves his son
and
you know i just imagine stephen king
throwing his whole
heart and soul into this book into this
character
and all of his fears about not
overcoming his alcohol addiction
i i think that that must be involved
it really moved me and i really cared
about these characters
not as scary as i would have hoped but
damn was it a good
read i can't wait to read more stephen
king i don't know
if anybody has suggestions about what
stephen king book i should read next i
have a few
maybe i can get to knowing me um
i i can be overly ambitious i will
probably try to read
it next or the stand or something when i
should probably just read
something a little shorter but this was
really fun to read the shining and
honestly i don't know why i haven't read
or
reading more stephen king books the
shining what else is there to say
right like and subscribe if you want me
to eat more crunchy
crunchy crunchy yummy yummy cookie
butter
and if you want me to stop i will never
stop
this is really bad for my health thanks
for watching